ضربات جويه استهدفت صباح السبت خطوطا
ومعدات رئيسيه للنقل الطاقه في منطقه
اوديسا وفقا للسلطات الاوكرانيه استخدمت
القوات الروسيه مسيرات ايرانيه من طراز
شاهد
للغايه اكثر من مليون ونصف مليون شخص من
الكهرباء لكن التغذيه الكهربائيه ستظل
متوفره للمرافق الحيويه طالما كان ذلك
ممكنا
هيئه الطاقه
حذرت من ان اصلاح الاضرار قد يستغرق ثلاثه
اشهر حاكم المنطقه اشار من جهته ان روسيا
استخدم الطائرات المسيره انتحاريه تطير
نحو هدفها بدلا من اطلاق الذخائر في ما
اكدت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه اسقاط عدد
من هذه المسرات وتستهدف موسكو محطات
الطاقه الحراريه والكهربائيه في اوكرانيا
بسلسله من الضربات منذ اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي في متعهد الرئيس الروسي مؤخرا
بمواصله ضرب شبكه الطاقه الاوكرانيه
على خط الموازن يستمروا القتال شرقي
البلاد وتحديدا على جبل التي تحاول القوات
الروسيه لاستيلاء عليها لتحقيق انتصار
معنوي بعد سلسله من الهزائم والانسحابات
ورغم سيطرته على عدد من البلدات لا يبدو
ان الجيش الروسي في وضع يسمح له بغزو
المدينه بعد استنزافه عسكريا واللوجيا ومع
بدايه فصل الشتاء يعتقد عدد من المحللين
ان خط المواجهه الحالي سيستقر بعد اسابيع
من التقدم الاوكراني في الشمال الشرقي وفي
الجنوب